欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课 店铺运营的过程中 很多人都说寻盘质量非常差
但是寻盘差 你要给出差的原因 或者是找到寻盘差的具体的问题 才能针对性的去解决问题
而不是当然说只知道回馈说寻盘质量差 即使业务回馈寻盘质量差 那么你也要让业务提供具体差在哪里
哪些维度可以调整 哪些维度还能够进一步的优化 我们才能够真正的针对性的去调整
而不是单单仅凭你口头说寻盘质量差就不行
这必须要通过原因分析以及数据的验证 才能够真正的判断是寻盘差 我们再针对性的去解决问题
第一个就是你的寻盘的来源的国家 是不是你的目标国家的寻盘
只有目标国家的寻盘成交概率才更大 因为非目标国家的寻盘虽然来得多
但是它对你的产品价格起定量等等可能都无法接受 所以说很难通交
这个无论你是L1还是L3 如果不是你们目标国家的寻盘
大概率也可能是算是低质量的 也就是L1到L3也可能算是低质量的
第二个就是目标国家为准确了 那么你买家的账号的等级是L1加
这样的买家才算质量更好一点 比如说这里的L1加里面还会有很多低质量的
那么我们L2到L3到L4 这种才是更加精准而且更加高质量的寻盘
那么第三个我们就要去看他这个账号采购的品类是否跟你们公司的相符
因为有些客户虽然说他有L2 L3 L4这么高层级的账号
但是他采购的品类非常的多 你们的品类可能只是他们品类中的某一个小支点
小分支 也就是他们销售你们这类产品 占比很小 那么这种占比小很有可能也不是你的目标客户
所以我们去判断品类的时候 最好去找那些主营的类目跟你们的品类是一致的时候
这种的买家他的一个采购量以及他的专业度才更高
所以说这个品类的判断也一定要去看
第四个就是寻盘回复 也就是你获得了这些优质的买家
虽然说看起来等级高 但是他的回复次数少
这种其实也是低质量的客户
因为你很难去盘活他 同时能跟他有更好的沟通
所以说这种账号你也要去关注
同时你要去看业务回复的话术
以及回复的内容怎么样 看看他们的回复是否比较合理
这也是影响寻盘回复的原因
有些寻盘是已读未回 已读说明他已经看到了
但是未回 为什么不回呢 很有可能是你写的内容
他不感兴趣 所以说这些都要进行一个深挖
才能够知道我们的寻盘到底是哪些方面不好
或者是说我们的业务觉得寻盘差 到底差在哪里
这样才能真正的找到具体的原因
然后我们去调整电波的时候 才能够更加的精准针对性的调整
所以想要提升我们的寻盘质量
第一 运营端要做 第二就是业务端也要做
也就是两个部门或者是两个岗位的人员都要统一去努力
第三个就是管理者 就是主管或者是管业务的或者是老板
你一定要让运营端能够同时的协作起来 而不是相互抱怨
只要他们相互抱怨 相互推卸责任 那么你这个店铺绝对又存在内耗了
你很多的资源都没有进行统一的调配
无法集中去提升店铺效果和提升寻盘的资料
所以只有你们共同协作 一起去分析 一起去研究
然后把具体的问题列出来 每个人负责哪部分改善哪部分
这样的话 我们的店铺才能够真正的改善
所以做好一个店铺需要大家一起协同去努力
不要总是在抱怨或者是相互推卸责任
只有共同去沟通一起去努力 一起去拿结果才能够共赢
好了 这节课我们就讲到这里 下节课我们再见